[Música]
Pues como siempre se acaban las noticias
y llega ya a revista de prensa hoy
tenemos aquí a nuestra compañera Marta
Moya bienvenida este viernes Marta Hola
Rodri Buenos días Muy buenos días vamos
a empezar en Francia que vive hoy una
jornada crucial y por eso nos traes tú
la portada del medio libagación uno de
los más importantes del país abren con
esa presencia policial frente al consejo
constitucional que les parece
preocupante que es lo que nos cuentan
Así es Rodri vamos a empezar con esta
portada del Liberación que titula
consejo constitucional con toda la
serenidad y vemos esa foto de Stefan mae
el periodista de la agencia reuters
cuando se ven a todos estos miembros de
los antidisturbios franceses A las
puertas del Consejo constitucional que
recordemos este viernes va a decidir si
valida total o parcialmente o rechaza
total y parcialmente la reforma
pensional de Manuel macron al rechazo a
la validación o al rechazo el Liberación
dice este las decisiones de la
Constitución previstas para este viernes
sobre la reforma de las pensiones
determinarán la continuación de la
crisis política y social que agita al
país desde hace meses Al Calor de esta
imagen de los policías frente al consejo
hemos destacado también una editorial
también de liberación Que firma Pablo
kiño que dice que las imágenes de los
gendarmes y de los antidisturbios ante
las puertas del Consejo
formalizan la incapacidad del gobierno
para llevar a cabo democráticamente una
reforma impugnada textualmente
Liberación dice las imágenes son una
locura y al mismo tiempo simbolizan el
inmenso desorden de la secuencia
política que Francia ha estado
experimentando desde enero realmente
impactantes esas imágenes de los
policías antidisturbios allí en París
Marta vamos a seguir con el medio France
enfoque habla de cómo va a seguir el
movimiento social el movimiento sindical
después de esta decisión del Consejo
constitucional
que es probable es lo que se espera no
contente a los manifestantes sí Rodri
destacamos un reportaje Que firma
Matilde en el que recogen testimonios de
algunos de los líderes sindicales
franceses que están a la espera de esta
decisión del Consejo dice este reportaje
que la expectativa en torno al consejo
constitucional nunca ha sido tan alta en
Francia por ejemplo citan al presidente
de la confederación de trabajadores
cristianos que dice que la movilización
es muy probable que no termine en la
noche de este viernes una vez el consejo
emita su veredicto haber convocado a los
manifestantes a la duodécima jornada de
huelga nacional en la víspera ayer
jueves es se vio como pues una decisión
de que pues la mayoría de franceses
siguen en contra de la reforma y además
pretende también ejercer un poco de
presión contra el gobierno de macron la
confederación de trabajadores cristianos
dice además que no la decisión del
consejo y que si es válida la reforma
pensional puede poner en suspenso las
movilizaciones seis meses pero que todo
va a estar de acuerdo con la
intersindical y que si el consejo da luz
verde a la celebración de un referéndum
es muy posible que se pongan manos a la
obra para recabar esos casi 5 millones
de firmas necesarios para que el
referendo se lleve a cabo desde luego
creo que tras este viernes no van a
seguir siendo buenos tiempos para el
gobierno de Manuel
vamos a cambiar de tema nos vamos hasta
Estados Unidos porque el New York Times
nos da un repaso de cómo se ha gestado
esa filtración de documentos luego de
que como hemos hablado también las
noticias Ya se haya detenido al presunto
autor de los documentos un joven de 21
años que trabajaba en la guardia
nacional Así es Rodri nos referimos a
Jack de sheira 21 años miembro de la
guardia Nacional del Estado de
Massachusetts datos sobre el que aporta
esta investigación de New York Times es
que en 2020 se alistó al ejército y
entró oficialmente al ala de
inteligencia de la guardia nacional
aérea en octubre de 2021 en esta
investigación de New York Times el medio
habla con miembros de ese grupo de
discord que es ese foro online donde
todo empezó
sostiene uno de estos miembros que te
sheira al ser ya bueno investigado y
parece que ya se iba a conocer su nombre
como autor de esta filtración envió un
último mensaje en el foro diciendo
chicos ha sido un placer Les amo a todos
y entonces empezó a cerrar todas sus
redes sociales recordemos que el FBI una
obra y media más tarde desde que el New
York Times identificara a esta persona
como el autor de las filtraciones lo
detuvo ayer el grupo donde todo nació se
llama Zack shaker Central es un grupo de
unas 20-30 personas donde jóvenes se
reunieron Al Calor de la pandemia para
compartir su amor por las armas memes
racistas así como jugar a videojuegos
con te
era el líder no oficial de este grupo y
quería impresionar a esos miembros del
grupo con esos documentos que fue
filtrando desde octubre del año pasado
hasta marzo de este año en total se
estima que fueron filtrados unos 350
documentos por los que el joven ahora
podría enfrentar una cadena perpetua y
viéndolo otros precedentes como los de
Julián a sans y Wikileaks no parece que
tenga buen futuro de ira Así es vamos
ahora con más noticias del continente
porque ayer Marta uno de los medios de
referencia en El Salvador anunció que
cambia su sede administrativa por los
ataques dicen a la libertad de prensa
del ejecutivo de nayib bukele sí Rodri
nos referimos al medio el faro un medio
que es muy crítico con el gobierno de
bukele que incluso ha denunciado ya
investigado esas presuntas negociaciones
entre la cúpula del gobierno y la cúpula
de las pandillas para reducir la
violencia a cambio de beneficios
penitenciarios 25 años después de que
para este medio en El Salvador ayer
cambió su anunció que cambió su sede
administrativa a San José a Costa Rica
Aunque mantendrá la redacción en el en
el Salvador el faro dice en su mensaje
de adiós dice que él desmantelamiento a
nuestra democracia la falta de controles
los ataques a la libertad de prensa y el
cierre de todo mecanismo de
transparencia amenazan seriamente el
derecho ciudadano a estar informado y
que por eso tomó esta decisión de
trasladar su sede administrativa a Costa
Rica bueno Marte y rápidamente vamos a
acabar con una noticia más amable porque
el semanario estadounidense Time anunció
ya sus 100 personajes más influyentes
del 2023 y hay algunos latinoamericanos
sí Rodri Como cada año el semanario ya
ha publicado su lista de los 100
personajes más influyentes de este 2023
tenemos desde el Rey Carlos III hasta la
baloncestista baloncestista
estadounidense hasta la primera dama
ucraniana oleena o el Premier ja sin
embargo nos destacamos en estos seis
personajes latinos que destaca la
revista Time que son el presidente de
Colombia Gustavo Petro el presidente de
Brasil Lula da Silva el actor chileno
célebremente conocido
Pedro Pascal la actriz mexicana Salma
Hayek el futbolista argentino Leo Messi
y la activista mexicana María Herrera
Magdalena con quién te quedas Marta yo
me quedo creo que con la activista
mexicana muy bien buena decisión Marta
Muchas gracias por este repaso y buen
fin de semana gracias